[Music]
i have the great pleasure today of
meeting
for the first time oddly enough
the illustrator of my new book beyond
order
this is yulia fogra also known as juliet
we're going to use julia it's very nice
to meet you
very nice to meet you my previous book
12 rules for life was illustrated by
ethan van siver and
i liked his illustrations a lot i
thought they were very successful
but he had other opportunities that he
was pursuing and so
i was obliged to find another
illustrator for
beyond order and i decided with my team
my daughter
and and my family members actually
mostly in discussion to
run a contest online and solicit
drawings i thought that would be
entertaining and interesting and perhaps
allow
someone an opportunity that they might
not otherwise have
obtained and so we received hundreds
and perhaps even thousands of of
um of illustrations of proposed
illustrations
do you remember yulia did i ask for the
illustration of a rule or more than one
rule was that how the contest ran
no i know exactly what you asked you
asked for one rule
first rule and you asked for line
drawing ah so it was a first rule line
drawing right because we needed
something that
would work well in black and white it's
a tricky thing to produce a
illustration for a book because it
whoever's doing the illustration has to
know enough about printing to ensure
that the illustration prints well
can be reproduced well in print format
and so
anyways we looked through a lot of um
we looked through a lot of artists
illustrations and
julia's stood out and i think that the
contest was in consequence very
successful
i'm very pleased with the illustrations
i think they have a interesting fairy
tale quality to them a
kind of classic fairy tale quality to
them a victorian quality as well
which seemed appropriate to the content
of the material
and so anyways we received julia's
entries and then worked with her over
well the contest was run in
it was march of 2020 march yep
march a year ago yes yes
and a very tumultuous year which is part
of the reason we haven't met
uh the pandemic lockdown of course has
ki bashed any plans we might have had to
get together
um you're based in new york correct
yes and so i un under normal
circumstances i'm going to new york
fairly frequently but
of course haven't been there for it's
got to be at least two years now
so what let's i'd like to find out some
things about you
so the first is tell us a little bit
about yourself
where are you from and and i'd like to
know a little bit about your life
yeah okay so i was born in riga
latvia one of the trio there is latvia
estonia and lithuania
baltic countries uh we are worth the mix
of poland and germany i would say and
the old city was built by german
but i lived in the area where i was the
only jew i'm jewish
i was the only jew and the rest of the
people were all russians there were no
latvians at all
and you would see in movies
nine-story buildings built like dominoes
it's all dominoes concrete
i hated it i saw a lot of that in moscow
it's endless an endless vista
of 20 floor high apartments stretching
as far as the eye can see in
every direction yeah it's very a very
um unwelcoming
architectural manifestation i would say
cold and harsh exactly
and i was young enough to go outside of
this neighborhood
if i were 15 or 16 i would be able to
start going outside and going alone into
the whole city into cafes
which we had but i couldn't so
by day let's go back
so i had a talent for music my mom was a
music teacher
and i had a perfect pitch luckily
so they tested me and they said i'm
i'm perfect for conservatory i was seven
they put me in a music conservatory
obviously no normal kid would
choose something like that for their
life it was
vicious it was um latvian training
combined with russian training what you
would see in chess clubs
it was vicious so tell us about that so
did you was that a residential school or
were you still living at home
i was still living at home and
how many hours a day would you spend at
school and practicing
so uh seven when i was seven i went to a
regular school and two music school it's
two different
places i had to travel by chembai
chambai is uh something you see in san
francisco
three or four stops not far away um
i had twice in a week
of a class two hour class and i had to
practice every day
at home for at least an hour and that
was my life
i also draw which was
a side project it wasn't taken seriously
by
anyone by me
your music was taken seriously by you
and your parents and
my parents and everybody around me and
kids in school and
i was known as a musician and did you
take any pleasure in that
was music good for you or what no no it
was
horrible it was very i was good at it
but this
it's uh i blame the teachers and i blame
the school because they would prepare
kids for orchestras
they will just process talented kids for
orchestras
there was no love of music involved at
all
it's something you saw in jane eyre
the teachers of jane eyre
[Music]
intimidating place that was music school
and we were playing classical music only
for seven years it was a classical
training
and i found that
believe in somebody else's tragedy it
was very sad the music was sad
and was not for me so by the end of
third year
i said i can't do it anymore i had a
crash i was on the floor crying
and my parents tried to convince me
nothing worked so my father said he took
the liberty of saying
he'll get me a puppy when i finish the
school
and i finished the school it was 1991.
and so how many more years did you go
after that event after that four years
so you worked four years for your puppy
yeah did you get them
no oh because i finished it in 1991 when
soviet collapsed
and we have to leave the country ah
right so
geopolitical restructuring got in the
way of your pet
yeah and we left to israel within the 91
your family left
israel and why why did you choose to
leave why did your family choose to
leave in 1991
uh soviet collapse uh 19 we left at 1992
the collapse was in 1990 right
it took us time so we lived through
bad times in latvia bad times in terms
of
food or anything really
there was no food yeah people don't know
a lot about that
post-soviet period in the west you know
i have my son-in-law
is russian i think he's about your age
um
he has some pretty harrowing stories of
early 1990s moscow
being afraid to go to school not knowing
if he was going to come home alive
rough it was a very rough period lawless
and chaotic period
by his account and and for you you said
food shortages
yeah my father stored potatoes and
tsuna for a year that's what all we ate
because there was nothing on the shelves
nothing
and how did you come across how did you
come across the tuna and the potatoes
and you have to ask my father ah okay
i don't know i wasn't involved in his
decisions and he stored it in a very
cool place
on the ground in someone's garage
i think
and bread was buy tickets i remember
staying in line
for an hour to get a piece of bread we
had tickets you can only get
one bread for three days i think i could
be mistaken
only one piece of bread there were two
choices of bread
in russia throughout soviet union white
bread
and rye bread nothing else so i was
standing for an hour
and people were spitting and angry and
i was a little girl but i got this bread
and i'm running home
and my mom is cutting the bread and it's
green completely green inside
so that was my life until 14 then we
left to israel
and did you encounter you said that you
were the only jewish family
or you said you were the only jew a
jewish family in the
in the entire area in the neighborhood
and
did you encounter prejudice because of
that or was that an invisible so of
course i was bullied
to hell and so was that a part of the
decision to go specifically to israel
yes and we had no other choices
germany was close to us america was
close to us that was the only choice
we didn't know anything about israel it
seemed like a nice place
from where i was i was very happy
because i felt
captive for 14 years i was trying to
escape this place in
any case in any price how large was your
family you have siblings
so uh most of my family was killed
uh during the holocaust 40 people
they just brutally killed everybody and
a very small portion left they survived
and that's why i'm here i have one
brother
and so your mom and dad and you and your
brother lived in this apartment building
in riga
yes how big was the apartment that you
and your brother and parents lived in
what they consider in america it's one
bedroom apartment
it's one room for us and a living room
for my parents
all right so you moved to israel in 92
92 and how old were you then 14
14. and how long did you your family
spend in israel
my family is still living there i think
your family's still there so was that an
improvement
no not for me for everybody else
everything seemed to be improving for
everybody else but me i couldn't find my
place i was always
not at home until i came to new york and
things have worked out for you in new
york absolutely well that's good so it's
obvious
that you're capable of finding a place
it just took a while
so what happened to you in israel why do
you think you had difficulty there
first of all we came with no language
second of all i came from europe to
middle east so it's a matter of
mentality i just couldn't get it
i just couldn't be part of it and we
lived in a very poor area
very poor area um
what did your parents do in israel how
did they keep
how did they make ends meet so my dad
became became he was an engineer and he
started working in some factory
my mom was working at nights in the
bakery
it was tough so they could find
employment but it was
it was it was tough yeah i started
working when i was
15 i've collected oranges
so you moved how old were you when you
arrived in israel
i was 14 almost 15.
right so that tends to be a relatively
tumultuous time and
in a girl's life anyways those teenage
years can and you didn't have
you couldn't speak the you couldn't
speak hebrew i wouldn't speak for two
years
for two years yep others could
speak three months just being just
listening
just being on the street they could
speak it's not how my brain works i had
to collect it for two years
and i couldn't get out anything of my
mouth and that's the problem i have with
languages
in general yeah well that
definitely sounds difficult so you when
did you move to new york how old were
you when you moved to new york
so in israel i stayed for nine years
i've been in the army which is a
separate subject to talk about
then i finished two years of art school
which was three school three years
but i only finished two and then i was
offered
by the head of our department i was
offered the job in her
private studio so i just
drop out i see so and that was you went
to art school
and that was on the basis of your
prowess in in visual art
yeah it was my dad's idea and you
had you stopped playing the piano by
this time oh i didn't play piano
from the moment i arrived to israel and
have you played it since
i've started to play new york that was
the first thing i bought
oh and have you been able to take any
pleasure in that
absolutely well that's great so that's a
happy ending to that story
and it's very rough becoming it can be
very rough
learning any uh sophisticated skill
because
the learning period is often not
particularly rewarding
there's so much you have to get by wrote
i mean when kids learn to read
they have to be able to read phrases and
perhaps even sentences
at something approximating a glance
before they take much pleasure in the
reading
and so there's this initial period of
rather painful apprenticeship
that's not necessarily that isn't
necessarily accompanied by
intrinsic pleasure and meaning but if
you can get through that if you're lucky
then
once you have the discipline you can
enjoy the skill
and i'm glad to hear that that worked
out for you are you a good pianist
i'm i'm good i just stopped playing
classical music
i was not meant to meant to be and what
music do you play and and what music do
you enjoy
rock pop house
uh-huh anything but right so you have a
modern sensibility
musically yep what about bands who do
you like
oh and there is a reason for that uh
my dad bought me a recorder for
cassettes took a set player
that was a
i was 11 or 12 max
and zuka says came along with it
one was queen and another billy joel
which queen album uh
i wish i remembered was it a night at
the opera
did it have bohemian rhapsody on it i
think so yeah
that's a night at the opera that's
definitely their best album
yeah and that's the first thing i i
listen to
and i remember just sleeping next to it
my my
my player was here i couldn't i couldn't
do anything else i was
possessed i was obsessed completely
obsessed i've never heard
or seen anything as beautiful
there was no beauty in my life it was
all monochrome
everything was black and white in this
area
yes physically there was no color even
the clothes were all black or dark brown
or dark blue
what are winters like in riga cold
minus two 20 celsius is
the coldest and we have to go to school
i remember that
so you moved alone to new york okay so
let's go back you said that you
you went to art school on the basis of
your talent as a visual artist
despite the fact that that wasn't
something that was that you really had
concentrated on with regards to training
you were trained as a child as a
musician not as a visual artist
how did you pick up that talent
i was the best in the class
how did they pick it up first of all i
didn't want to go to school
of graphic arts because of computer
training i said i'm never going to touch
this thing
technology i can't i'll never acquire
something like that that's too much of a
skill and technology is not for me
so they said first year you'll always
only have to draw by hand
everything we're gonna do we're gonna do
by hand no computer involved
and they bought me they they bought me
completely with that
so first year everything we've done was
drawn and did you had to submit a
portfolio i presume as a
as an uh condition of admittance yes and
you'd be drawing
on your own did your parents support
that or were they opposed to it or was
it was it neutral before that
they supported it yeah okay oh and they
didn't see that as something
no my parents were musicians they were
the hipsters of the area
considered the hipsters they were the
the free spirits
the art was supported
and how much time did you spend drawing
when you were a kid a lot
i was not just drawing i was making
mosaics
mosaics out of what out of wooden
colorful
different shaped and
what you have to do is just imagine what
you want to build
and just go for it from the center
outside and the size i've built it it
was the size of
almost a small rug it was that big of a
bag
and i would spend two three hours it was
a blessing
so then you went to art school and you
spent the first year drawing by hand
and that was okay you were afraid of
technology or loath to use it so that so
that was that what happened in the
second year
i just grasped it it's just i just went
along with it
and so you learned to use completely
fine you you became fluent with the use
of computers then
better than everybody else ah so what do
you think
made you believe to begin with that you
weren't able to do it
or that you weren't suited for it i'm
just afraid of technology
well you should be everybody should be
afraid of technology
but it's still probably better to know
how to use it i think you should be less
afraid of it perhaps if you know how to
use it
it's very powerful i mean technology has
disrupted my life
in a manner that is absolutely not only
inconceivable but
perhaps irrecoverable but anyways
um you know it's brought many benefits
as well but it's so powerful you you're
taking a tiger by the tail
or perhaps something much bigger than a
tiger
so you're playing dragons yeah yeah or
maybe they're eating you
it depends so all right so you
you you learned you became sophisticated
sophisticated technology user your
second year of art school
so what advantages and disadvantages
were there to bringing computer
technology to your artistic endeavors
photoshop is a unique thing i would
never be able to
layer up players the way i do or
imagine things the way i imagined before
i start
i don't think of graphics in terms of
non-photoshop anymore
it's an unbelievably powerful program
it's like a factory
photoshop there's there's there's no
limit to what you can do with an image
it's it's actually it's kind of a
terrifying program in some sense because
it can if you're the least bit obsessive
it can pull you in and trap you forever
because
there's no limit to the number of
variations you can produce and i
i mean i'm a rather amateur photoshop
user i've used it a fair bit but i
certainly haven't explored all of its
capabilities it's
it you can spend a lifetime doing that
absolutely
i hope doing that that's my that's your
lifetime
that's my goal so okay so you you you
finished two years of
art school and then you were offered a
position by the director of the program
yes and that was still in israel yeah
and what did
she or he that was a she what did she
have you doing and why and why did
why and did what did she think about
your decision to stop going to art
school to
take your job she noticed me
uh she noticed me and she came to a
graduation and we had a final project
she was there the whole time and after
the final project she said
can i speak to you and i thought i'm in
trouble
and she offered me because first of all
i spoke russian and she had
a client and second of all i was good
that's what she told me i had no idea i
didn't believe anything she said
i was completely um
living outside of myself at that point
what do you mean
living outside of yourself it's hard to
describe i couldn't fit into israel
right i felt so large for that place
and nobody knew what i'm speaking about
so how long did you work for her for
four months
uh backing up
when i was 15 i met a boy on the street
it was two weeks after i arrived and
that boy is my husband right now so he
left
to new york in 2000 in 2000
and i followed him i see and so
and was that what stopped you from
continuing the job
yes uh-huh that's exactly what stopped
me he's leaving his departure was
uh devastating
did when he departed had you two plan to
meet up again in new york was that the
other day
and what changed he stayed here for
three months
he looked he called me and he said i'm
seeing people
and i don't see them they own
transparent i'm just looking through
them
i don't see any of them you need to come
because i see you
and so you uprooted yourself from israel
how old were you
i was 23. again no english
no language only had this abc
again the same story just this time i
came along
but you like new york not right away
not right away um
it was tough it was tough in the
beginning and we had the first child
a year later i would describe my life as
40 years in the desert
that's exactly what it was 40 even more
42.
how old are you now 43.
[Music]
that's not many years out of the desert
no it's just the beginning
all right so you're in new york and
you're learning to speak english you're
newly married you have a new child yes
and again two to three years it took me
to start
speaking and i wouldn't just
the words would scatter around my head i
would just not be able to find them
they're always hiding behind
there's a field and i know they're there
but they hide in behind the rocks
it's very complicated it's very hard for
me to speak
because words um i see words
i don't hear words for me words are
pictures
and i memorize them and when they are in
the sentence
i'm being able to reread that's why it
was so good
for me that we corresponded because i
could reread and i could understand
exactly what you mean
and then did you um when when you
arrived in new york did you work as an
artist
right away you did fun
yeah how how did you find work it's hard
to find work as an artist so how did you
manage that
i thought i'm gonna clean the restroom
so i was walking around looking for
orthodox schools or shoes
just to clean the bathrooms that's what
i thought i'm gonna do
um two weeks passed and i went to photo
developing studio we had some
photographs it was the winter it was
beautiful
i came there and the guy before me
wanted to make some detachment on his
old pictures
and the guy in front of me at the desk
said yes we do that but it's going to
take us a month
come back to us in a month so i'm
getting to the desk and i'm saying i can
do it in one hour
maybe less he said
i don't believe you let me try he sat me
down and he had a drawer
with probably 10 pictures that was
supposed to take
him a month to retouch and i've done it
in one day
he said i have somebody in mind it was a
jewish guy obviously
they had somebody in mind in new jersey
which is fun
that's how i got my job and i stayed
there for 13 years
and so tell me about this place or it
was a photo studio
no he told his friend obviously and he
had friends
in graphics i see more than that
um there was a catalogue company
that was creating catalogs for mostly
jewelry but not only
mostly jewelry which is the hardest
thing because uh
retouching of jewelry is the hardest
thing and we had everything we had
a printing facility
under our roof in the same building we
had
our photographers who had me so
everything was going on i was on top of
everything
he made me an art director and i was an
art designer and art director
and the company closed up in two
thousand
was it sixteen it was five years ago
and you managed that was your english
functional by that point or
i wouldn't say so nope
uh we didn't need to speak a lot he
he learned to trust me within a year he
knew
he just knew that everything i do is
gonna be lovable
and he knew i'm always right he just
figured it out
just do that just do this i worked three
days a week
which was amazing i got my salary for a
week
i had two boys but that time
and i got sick oh what happened
um well i'm not sure i'm still not sure
what happened i was always sick
i relapsed and i was destined to stay
home
so i stayed home and there was one
choice either
i should suffer from pain or i should do
something while i'm suffering from pain
and that was the only thing that
made me disappear i feel i forget about
the reality that's the only thing my
photoshop
and i've started doing graphics for no
reason
okay so when did this happen when when
so you
you got too ill to work was that the
case you got too ill to work and so you
were staying at home when
when did that happen five years ago
five years ago i'm skipping i'm skipping
that's okay
we should move towards the discussion of
the drawings anyways but we're getting
close to
we're getting close to the present day
so you became ill
about five years ago yeah and you did
you have to stop
no i was ill but i became very ill
i i didn't think i will survive it
and you don't i don't want to press you
any more than is
is comfortable for you but i had no
energy
at all zero and i had two kids
and you talked about pain as well yeah
the pain was tremendous and then i got
also on top of it i got fibromyalgia
they they couldn't treat and the pain
with fibromyalgia that you can treat it
with medicine
anyway so i thought what would i do with
my life i'm 40 i was almost 40.
okay i'll paint with oil paintings on
canvas
out of the bloom and it worked
and every painting was better than
another
i was keeping it a secret and my husband
said you can't keep it a secret people
must see it so seeing what why
i couldn't grasp the idea of somebody
else's seeing my work
i've done this for two years and
eventually i had
a show in chelsea new york
in the gallery it didn't go so well
and i knew that i have to switch it was
so hard physically too so hard for me to
paint
too hard to paint to paint here so
sitting in front of the
desk was an option for them
that's how i started doing graphics so
i'm at agora galleries page
yes which will link into the into this
and there's a number of images there an
orange a tangerine
my mistake um
a painting called accepted these are oil
on canvas
and i haven't seen them since before
they're um they're as good as i would
expect
given your illustrations and do you
do you use any digital technology when
you're doing your oil paintings
no not at all so that's tell me a little
bit about how you go about it
they're they're beautiful i was just
trying
to copy exactly what i see in a
photograph those things
if you see only were there cops
you would see it on my website cops is
my favorite three cups coffee
oh yes there are close-ups so you can
see actually up close they enormous
those paintings 48 by 30.
and these are done from photographs yep
wow
i made something similar to this one
where you use squares
um i read it i redid a uh
uh famous oil painting by
now i can't remember his name
unfortunately it's a reclining nude
and pixelated it in large cubes and then
cut it out of styrofoam
uh foam core and layered it like my maps
of meaning painting
i did about 10 of those when i was in my
mid-20s and i haven't done any since
i i like these three at the bottom are
very reminiscent of that
they're yeah they're really um they're
very intense
have you been successful as a fine
artist
have you been able to make a living no
no well it's very difficult to make a
living as a fine artist
i was able to spend everything i had in
my savings
yes aha yeah and these people asked for
uh they call
gizly prints yes print on canvas
and special color not just regular
prints you have
done some money but not for living maybe
no
no and have you been successful at
selling your original images
no not at all and any idea why
i mean apart from the general
impossibility of doing that right it's a
very
finite market and it's extraordinarily
difficult for a fine artist to make a
living
it happens almost never so it's not
surprising
but the images are very of are a very
high quality
in my opinion um
that doesn't necessitate success i mean
part of the problem of being an artist
is that you have to compete
with the production of all artists
living and dead
and it takes a long time to build a
reputation
and you have to know how to you have to
know the gallery system
and you have to be able to market
yourself and you have to be able to sell
yourself and
or someone else has to do it it's
exactly and i was not ready for that
i didn't like the i didn't like this
combination of words selling yourself i
knew
i had to sell myself and i didn't want
to do that so i just well
you know this is a good place for this
discussion i would say
it might be useful for people who are
listening who are artistically inclined
it's not the right thing it's not the
right way to construe it as selling
yourself
what you have to understand is that
there's no possible way of being
successful if people don't know who you
are or what you've done
because very few people buy art and so
you have to communicate with a lot of
people before you'll get
any interest that could be turned into
revenue
and so you have to communicate and
obviously you have to communicate
because you have to have a market
and it's just as important to know how
to communicate or perhaps even more
important than it is to know how to
produce things that are beautiful and of
value
and if you think about it as
communication it's less off-putting than
if you think about it as selling
yourself it's still a tremendous
problem i mean no matter what you
produce
regardless of its value a huge part of
the problem you'll face trying to
monetize it is
communicating its existence
so and artists are rarely not only
rarely trained
in doing that but are also frequently
somewhat
temperamentally disinclined to do it
absolutely so so
that's so that's a warning to all of you
out there who are artistically inclined
if you want to make a living
especially independently you had better
be prepared to learn how to communicate
it with everything at your disposal and
put as much
effort into that if you can as into your
art itself
that's that again that's not necessary
if all you want to do is produce art but
if you want to produce art and
live it's necessary i've listened to
your lectures yes yeah yeah well
it's hard one knowledge i've produced
items for sale
you know prior to my books say and
i thought they were quite useful these
programs i've developed with my
colleagues to help people
write a life plan that's self-authoring
and to
assess their personality but
the it wasn't until i was able to
communicate with a very large number of
people that those products became
remotely successful
despite their quality let's say yeah
yeah so can i ask you just out of
curiosity and don't feel inclined to
answer this
how many of your paintings have you sold
one
three three yeah that was three
i was commissioned to do two and does
agora gallery
still represent you do you have
galleries that represent you no no
absolutely not
for one month only for one month only
that was the show
yeah and people but people can contact
you through your website
yes every piece of information about me
is in my website
are the prices of your artworks on your
website nope
why not i'm not saying they should be
i'm
i'm curious i just think they shouldn't
i think
um i should communicate with people
first that's part of communication
i don't have a set price it depends
all right so let's talk about this
contest
and so why don't you tell me the story
because i don't know the story
and so i'd really like to hear it
yeah i don't know the story on your end
i didn't just know the story on my end
i have no idea why i was chosen i never
asked this question i never wanted to
know
today i'll ask you it's chosen because
in my opinion and also the opinion of
the people i had
helping me make the decisions your
drawings were
they were clearly the best of all the
drawings that we had all the
pieces of art they're not exactly
drawings you can describe more what they
are
um they were they were
better than any of the others that we
received and i would say markedly so
um so that's that's the simple
explanation
um we felt very fortunate that the the
contest had produced
such a positive result so
with lockdown and with my state of
health it was quite difficult to
find another illustrator to even know
how to go about that
so the contest came up as an idea and
i don't know not a bad idea well it
we'll see won't we but i'm i'm very
pleased with
with the way that it's turned out so
okay so
so how did you remember how you found
out about the contest
i remember everything yes uh i had a
friend
lawrence fox he lives in the uk he's an
actor
and musician and right now he organized
the party
he's in politics now so he sent me the
link
of your twitter i was evening
and i was sitting with my husband
drinking tea in the kitchen
and i was sitting like that and i never
sit like that and i was ready to rip up
my hair because i really wanted it and i
told him
there is no way i can't make lined art
he said do your thing i said no
you don't understand it's jordan
peterson he knows exactly what he wants
when he says line dart it has to be
produced in lines and i just can't do
that
you have to do your thing just do your
thing some people just don't know
until they see it so my teacup
was standing on those
can you see yes put a little closer
yes these are german drawings and my mom
bought them in hamburg
and i was looking in the sky and i was
looking at the lights
and i said this is my thing he said do
it
go right now so you saw the contest
announcement
on twitter yeah see i don't even
remember how we announced it but
obviously we used twitter i kept the
screenshot
i don't remember much of this at all
yeah and i remember why i wanted it so
bad
i wanted it because i wanted to make you
smile
i wanted now why did you care about that
so first of all did you you
knew about me yes before that how i knew
about you before that
for a long time but i never followed you
because i'm not following everybody
it's just a habit so how did you know
how did you come across my work lawrence
fox
he sent me the link on the same day
and that day i was thinking why but
you're so sorry sorry to interrupt you
but you said
that you when he sent you the link
did you already know about my work yes
you did how did you and so what the vid
videos or had you read my previous book
lectures no lectures i was listening to
your art lectures
i see okay you're listening to my
lectures on art oh yeah
you you you gave a lecture in
toronto museum i think yes that's the
one i love
i've listened to it three times i think
uh i think that was in ottawa
at the national gallery and i did one at
the national gallery and i did one on
the meaning of music at a museum in
toronto
but that's not the one you're referring
to no
i wish i could find it i need to find it
i need the links as well
so i went ahead i went downstairs
and i knew i can't do that in in
drawings so
what i did at the time i would do photo
montages
black and white photo montage meaning
meaning i would make a list of keywords
something i need for that and i knew i
need the sky
i knew i need a guy and a special
character not just any guy
i wanted him to be proud and
what's the word a slightly arrogant this
was the first rule
the first goal do not carelessly
denigrate social institutions or
creative achievement and
i sent out suggestions right i the
suggestion was the
uh uh a tarot card yeah you sent
one tarot card from the rider deck i
believe it was the rider deck
so uh i would create that and then
i would just start searching the web
and that could be a photo that could be
part of the painting i would just
collect in
very chaotic way very neurotic and
chaotic for
three four hours i'll just
pick up the stuff everything i see
everything i see useful
everything i see fit i would collect
then i see a plain page that is scary
and i knew that i'm gonna sit 12
not one usually i see one i would have
to deal with 12
and i knew i can do it but usually i'll
drop myself
into the world i'll just drop myself
into something impossible and see
if i can survive that's what i do
so i photo montage this
out of pieces just like the mosaic
that's why
that's why i spoke of making a mosaic
from center
out i would find the heart of the image
and i'll work
towards the edges then i'll have to
flawlessly
integrate them into each other there are
probably hundreds
yeah there is a hundred pieces here from
all sort of sources
and why did you decide to use a photo
montage rather than draw
my thing it's my thing he told me just
do your thing that i see
okay that's how you see things okay so
show bring the image up again let me let
me make some comments about it
and i can tell you okay so um
i like the melody of the
main figure there's something musical
about it
and about the way that i i guess it's
the
it's the lines of the standing figure
and the dog
and the butterfly it it fits
harmoniously together and
you you got it right to have him looking
up into the sky like he's preoccupied
and
even though he's hypothetically about to
step off this clip cliff the way that
you
produce this is similar to the way that
i write because
i collect all sorts of things and then i
array them and then i edit them
and edit them and edit them and edit
them and edit them until i
end until i can't edit them anymore and
then i'm done
um so when i saw this
the first thing i i believe i thought
was that it was beautiful
and that that that was
a necessary criteria for for for my
satisfaction um
and it was there's nothing about your
drawings that are
foolish or trivial and so
and i like the classic element and so
when i saw this well i was
very happy i thought well that'll be a
beautiful addition to the
to the book so you sent the fool
you're speaking my language first of all
every words word
that's exactly how i feel i i had to
create
shape wise something harmonious
perfectly harmonious
it has to be balanced out perfectly
otherwise it's junk
and whenever that's very difficult to do
you see people often when they make a
portrait even very talented people
can't array the multiple if there's
multiple figures they can't array the
multiple figures
together so that they look either
like they're dancing let's say like
they're related to each other properly
they look like separate figures sort of
stuck on a page and
certainly that isn't the case with your
illustration of the fool
and often people would ask me
who am inspired by no one
they would not believe me uh it's
definitely look like that oh it's
definitely look like door
well it's definitely look like this guy
and the guys definitely look like my
brother
it's none of those things i never get
inspired by visuals
i get inspired by music
so here we come a full circle because i
always knew that i have to choose either
music
or drawings two things and i knew i have
to choose because
when you're little grown-ups would say
what do you want to be when you grow up
which implies you have to choose
and i didn't want to choose well it's so
interesting that
you think of your drawings musically
given that that's how they struck me and
that's how they struck you
the words word so what i do is i put my
music
and i work only to music nothing else i
have no ideas
and i'm trying to turn my head off
i'm not thinking during this chaotic
picking i have to analyze like good bad
bad bad
right but then when it's all done
it's pretty much like um what actors do
master actors with method acting
they just collected all this information
yeah they know everything about
they dressed up and they just being and
i can't control this
when i attach those things i'm just i'm
just the tool
i can't think once i started thinking
i'm ruined
right well yeah
thinking is perhaps reserved for
critical judgment rather than creative
production
yeah you have to open yourself up to a
kind of attention
and it's interesting that you know you
say you you collected a very large
number of
items to work with it's initial over
production followed by
selection and that's another thing
useful for people who are listening to
this or watching it might want to know
like when i write i write way more than
i keep
and then i can select and so i don't
constrain myself to begin with i can
write down whatever i want knowing full
well that i'm going to
modify it or throw much of it away
so i sent like i had images in mind
photographs paintings that that captured
the theme of what i wanted to portray
in the illustration for the chapter and
so as we progressed through the
12 i had sent an image or two or three
perhaps i don't exactly remember
that sort of hinted at what i was
looking for
and so then you you worked off that
initial
suggestion but you produced something
that was
in that vein but not by any means the
same thing
so let's go through let's go let's show
everybody the illustrations one by one
and talk
about each of them so we saw number one
the fool yeah i had much more obviously
i had much more i had mountains i had
extra stuff and i always minimize it
not necessary out not necessary out i
simplified it completely
then i went to number five
rule five that's do not do what you hate
and so that's lucifer plummeting
from heaven
yeah that's the one and tell me about
that
that's my favorite rule
that's your favorite rule is that you
mean the favorite illustration or the
rule itself
now you hadn't read the chapters i don't
believe
i did you did okay okay so i sent them
to you
yes okay well that was wise that was
appropriate
yeah that was wise i asked for it but
then
i stopped myself from reading on
most of them i didn't want i i didn't
want
to translate them into words and vice
versa
okay so but you had read the chapter for
rule five
yeah you gave me very clear uh
three paragraphs on each rule and that
was more than enough and you showed
pictures
i have it here we can attach it and we
went back and forth on this image quite
a lot
on this one no the only change here was
that the the hand was too long right arm
length
well that happens to stick in my mind so
that may not be an
uh accurate representation of what
happened
so tell me about this image again it has
that lovely harmony you know
the the character looks like he's the
the figure looks like he's dancing
it's beautiful yeah so i was inspired by
um ballet dancer
and i didn't want it to look too much
like this because they similar
in in description right you want him to
be
all the way down on the ground i wanted
him be in the middle
and it was very challenging very
challenging
because the emotion is so contradictory
to me and i was trying to catch it in
one frame
and the emotion was he's still falling
he's not there yet
it's quite interesting
he's desperate and angry
and hopeful it's a great expression
and he's looking for help yeah well and
i believe you can see all of those
things in the expression there's a
pleading
in it yeah so once i get the face i
would change the face of a person
obviously
uh unrecognizably
for others and i'll work on a nose
obviously and i'll work
on the eyes and then i'll change the
emotion i i'll actually work on
on the flaps of the skin to make him
more desperate
the darker the area on top of his eye
the more desperate he is there are ways
to work on a motion
to change it slightly and i'm changing
it only on one half of the face
that's my trick the other half of the
face would
describe a different motion
and so how did you discover that
technique okay uh
actually there is a filmmaker
first filmmaker his name is george
melius he was french
the one who created moon what was the
name
i have it write it down he created
[Music]
what's his name we needed a trip to the
moon oh yes the
very early film maker he was the first
very famous film yeah so um
he has been depicted in hugo cabrera
by martin scorsese film right yeah so
there i saw how he created the magic he
wanted some
a man disappeared so he would take the
canister
of the film take the actual film get to
that
point cut out a few frames
where the person disappears and glue it
together
so and this then i notice the same idea
in music
when i'm listening let's say to sting he
will do exactly the same thing he will
take the emotion
that comes to the point of um
i forgot the word the musical term
he will cut the other half he'll take a
different emotion
cut over the beginning glue them
together and that creates a completely
different emotion
in music nobody's using it unless you're
genius
and why the reason is because the church
would forbid
it in the very early stages because
those chords would create doubt
doubt and uncertainty so those chords
sound beautiful and
slightly bitter and sophisticated
it you'll never hear it in music
especially classical music
so i've started to think how can i
recreate it visually
same thing so you showed
rule 11 so let's jump to that one unless
you have a preference
that's do not allow yourself to become
resentful deceitful
or arrogant and that's satan in hell
and that's modeled after an illustration
from paradise lost by gustav dore if i
remember correctly
so why don't you tell us about that
illustration
again there is not much to tell i was
trying to recreate one of those
and i was trying to be simplistic about
it obviously
showing a big distress devastation
that's how i show devastation
yes and that's devastation wrought by
becoming resentful deceitful and
arrogant
so and the point of the chapter at least
in part is that even if you have reasons
for all of those three things
especially resentment because people
often have extraordinarily difficult
lives
going down that path is likely to make
everything worse
and that's a non-trivial problem because
if you're suffering dreadfully then
it's very difficult to resist the
temptation
of resentment so
it's something i've certainly struggled
with that rule in rule 12 be grateful in
spite of your suffering
those are rules that i've had a very
hard time
abiding by what's that that took me the
longest this role
i've created three or four different
versions and i worked and worked and
worked and i was not satisfied
yes this yeah
all right let's go to let's go to rule
do you have an order you
prefer sure we go to rule two rule two
okay rules so i've done the last
the best for last
imagine who you could be and then aim
single-mindedly at that
that was a tricky one to have you do
because the chapter is an analysis of an
old alchemical drawing
and so you had to be constrained in in
the recreation of that
because it had to duplicate all the
elements of the original drawing or my
chapter wouldn't have made any sense
so which made it easier for me
being constrained is easy
i know exactly what's supposed to be
there
yes well people with an artistic
temperament or maybe people with a
wannabe artistic temperament often
rail against constraint but
it's you want a lot of constraint
generally speaking
otherwise you drown in choice and
that's that's a big problem so this
chapter
describes this picture as a story that
proceeds from the bottom up you can take
it in at a glance but it also proceeds
from the bottom up
and it's the emergence of personality
well-developed personality from from
nothing in some sense or from potential
that's another way of thinking
about it and it's an unbelievably
sophisticated image
and which is why it takes me a chapter
to
unwrap some of it so
um what what
did you what was the experience for you
of working on this image
i figured i was looking for one of the
paintings to make
inverted as opposed to
as opposed to black figures on white
background which is usually the case
i've done it inverted and i loved it i
loved how it's black
as opposed to every original i saw on
the internet
that makes it very magical
uh there are dragon there so
the way the picture works just as a hint
is that
well the bottom sphere in some sense
represents that which attracts your
interest and
then that can transform itself into that
which you're afraid of
so you might have an ambition for
example to pursue something you're
interested in
but then that turns into a dragon
because you're afraid of pursuing it but
if you do confront it then that turns
into
you that that helps you develop your
personality
that's that's that image in a thumbnail
um it's much more to it than that of
course
i love it rule four
oh that's rule sorry that was rule two
yes imagine who you could be and then
aim single-mindedly at that
this is rule three is the one we need
rule three is michaela's favor do not
hide unwanted things in the fog
right and this is the opposite of hiding
unwanted things in the fog
this is confronting them and that's
a variant of saint george and the dragon
which is an unbelievably
pervasive mythological and artistic
motif
and perhaps also the oldest
story that we have the oldest stories
that we know
are variants of king george and or saint
george and the dragon
so tell me about this one
that was difficult um
because there were too many items to
that shouldn't look separated although
the woman should be separated
um so what i've done is
using a fabric fabric of hers and fabric
of his
uh flying into the same direction and
that's the connecting
point um castle should be separated so i
wasn't worried about
the castle but the dark sky and the
dragon
work in um
sure 45 degrees yeah right absolutely so
the mass
of the dragon and the mass of the sky
are balanced against the
yeah against the rider and that gives it
a symmetry across the
uh from the top left corner to the
bottom right corner
yeah absolutely draw a line there it's
symmetrical across that axis
and the castle had to be there and the
dragon had to be there and the woman had
to be there all those elements are
crucial
and so this is what you do when you
don't hide things in the fog you
confront them
and you free something of value as a
consequence
that's that's a that's
the most one of the most magnificent
discoveries of human beings that human
beings have ever made and
images like this are an attempt to make
that conscious to serve to
to they're they're they're they're a
guide to a particular kind of
action in the world that's the voluntary
confrontation with things you don't
understand and that
you are afraid of and the promise that
something
of extreme value will emerge as a
consequence of that even though it looks
dire initially and can be i mean this is
no joke because
if you go off to fight dragons there's
always the possibility that you'll die
or worse and that's a real possibility
it's it's not something that can be hand
waved away with any amount of
psychological
um nonsense let's say
these are real battles not merely
psychological battles
rule four please stop me too if there's
anything else you want to say about any
of these images i
i really want to hear what you have to
say rule four
notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated
atlas
and there's three women in the
background why that was
part of your suggestion so i have to say
why
you have to say why
well i would say that to the degree that
men are properly shouldering their load
then women can rejoice and play in the
background
which is not to say that all women do is
rejoice and play
no one lives like that but it's very
difficult to rejoice and play
when responsibility remains unshouldered
so
and it is the case that each of us lift
the world up onto our shoulders in one
way or another or fail to do so
um it's a terrible burden but it's a
meaningful one
rule five we did rule five sorry go
ahead
uh i've made it theatrical if you see on
top
it's like a part of the scene that makes
sense more
yeah this is part of the scene because
you can see the fabric on top
right here like and they dancing on the
background
so it's like a stage setting something
like that that was my idea
yeah well what we play out on the stage
are representations of things that we
should
play out in our life or sometimes
they're opposite because
you know if you see a villain on the
stage
and he ends badly then the lesson is to
not be a villain
but that's a still imitation it's just
imitation in the of the reverse
rule six because we did rule five
abandoned ideology abandoned ideology
and that's as that's your version of a
soviet-era propaganda poster
yep
now you must have seen many of those
when you were in riga
no i haven't seen any of those because i
was born in 1977.
my mistake so tell us about this image
not much to tell i wanted her to look
mean cruel
bitter just like the women i saw
in riga 1977 the women looked like that
russian woman why
why they would be there um i guess we're
thinking that it was
had something to do with ideology
and its terrible grip the terrible grip
that ideology had on
well certainly the people in the soviet
union but also in the entire world
was unbelievably catastrophic
a whole century of catastrophe of
terrible catastrophe for
hundreds of millions of people and we
still haven't learned our lesson
and people can object that you can't
help but think ideologically and
i don't believe that to be the case no
i'm the product of that and i can tell
you that
for me it's a given that things can
change within one night it's a given
because it happened
people in america cannot imagine such
thing because things gradually
went better and better and slightly
better maybe a bit worse but better and
better
you cannot imagine because they never
lived it
and things were taken away one night
everything changed
well people got a bit of a taste of that
this year i would say
even so and hopefully it won't go beyond
the taste that we've had so
i guess you you follow an ideology when
you
you have the over weaning desire to
explain more of the world than you can
explain it's very complicated
your representation of the world becomes
something you proudly display
to indicate your moral superiority
and you'll sacrifice people to that
rule seven work as hard as you possibly
can on at least one thing
and see what happens i love this is
beautiful it's so playful
it's got the it's got this feeling of a
of a child's fairy tale but one that's
not
speaking down to children and there's
real love in it
and it's very frequently the case that
mentoring relationships apprenticeship
relationships have that love in them
this shoemaker is teaching this young
boy to a craft that will
enable him to do something productive
but also
enable him to live to to provide him
with a living
and he's off he's the good father like
gepetto he's obviously pleased
that his apprentice is showing mastery
and that's the definition of a good
father
perhaps a good parent that you're
pleased when your son or your daughter
advances even when they advance beyond
you which hopefully they will if you're
highly successful
there's a lot of love in this
illustration as far as i'm concerned
yeah i've tried to appeal to you if you
look at the old guy
he's a young character
i can't believe you haven't noticed
the list of things that i haven't
noticed would fill many many books
that's so smart
that's so smart the lovely character
this guy
and the the the room that you've you've
portrayed there is
it's a place of productive activity it's
it's inviting and you
you did you made it theatrical again
with the um
with the with the fabric along the top
and so it's like we're looking into a
private moment exactly the fact that
it's theatrical
so tell me so this is this
you've done this with a number of images
what possessed you to do that
my experience my own experience i
suppose
i've had that with my grandmother why
make it thi
why make it why making it theatrical yes
and so
so overtly it's perfectly appropriate
especially given the the tenor of the
book i'm not sure again
uh i'm not sure about most of my
decisions i wouldn't
yes well that's the problem with if
artists can say what they do they
wouldn't need to do their art
i suppose i don't know that's left to
other people often
and some of the worst claptrap ever
produced is analysis of art
often by the artists themselves but
often by critics as well
well you open up the curtains on a scene
and to open up the curtains on a scene
is to indicate
that this scene is of importance because
otherwise why put it on the stage why
open the curtains why say that this is
here for your
for your consideration and so you're
displaying to the viewer something
of crucial importance here is that this
relationship exists and it's
it's healthy and positive yeah and
something
very yes and it's intimate as well yes
exactly
yes lovely a beautiful favorite
yes and you you managed to imbue this
illustration with sentiment without it
being maudlin
or naive or or saccharine
or sugar-coated any of that and that's
very tricky thing to do to make
something positive
and and joyful and loving like that
without it degenerating into
sentimentality
yeah with the boy i was struggling
because
many boys have increased emotions
they're very emotional
and i needed to show a sense of oh
but every boy i tried i probably tried
20.
um didn't work until i found this
picture of my son 10 years ago
he was making bubbles soap bubbles
in the original picture and he looked at
them without
um overly expressing
his joy and that's the moment i like
it's something in between
right so he's contemplating yes
happily he's not sure if it's good or
not but the father approves
great rule eight
is irises try to make one room in your
house
in your home as beautiful as possible
i tried that multiple times and it's
been it was extraordinarily useful
to try to make a room beautiful or more
than one room it's such a good
exercise to learn to cultivate a
relationship with beauty
it's in a world where so much as ugly as
beauty is
as sustaining as bread perhaps even more
so
and so this is a
um a testament let's say to vincent van
gogh's irises which at one point was a
painting that sold for more than any
other painting had ever sold for
170 odd million dollars if i remember
correctly i'm sure that record's been
broken since then
but it's of great interest to note that
the most expensive artifacts in the
world are
artistic artifacts and in principle
those that
speak remind us of beauty
and the chapter rule seven rule eight
try to make one room in your home as
beautiful as possible is a
meditation on the ability of art to
remind us of what we've forgotten
so tell me about the choices you made in
this image
so the original irises the jug is
very tiny and very much looks like his
face with an ear
the original gel
and i couldn't use that so i needed a
different jug and i needed it to be
[Music]
rural nothing more i needed
in the wood the place and i needed more
than that
i was looking at those and i was not
sure this is irises by van gogh
until i found a way to make it his with
the portrait
on the background that is clear
and also um it's slightly off-centered
and slightly looks like a mistake
but thanks for for his face it's
perfectly harmonious within the page
you see that it's slightly off
but it's not so that's part of what
makes a
vid a piece of visual art work is
the the relationship between the images
and their hypothetical mass
it's something like that they have to be
balanced properly on the page
absolutely so you pick
you you talked about the rural rural
nature of the jug
and the plain wood table that it's
sitting on
that's to not take away from the flowers
well every artist directs the attention
of his or her viewer
now the attention is on irises
so you make decisions often this is one
of the
reasons i believe that hand-drawn
animated art is preferable to
computer-generated
animated art often computer
animation allows animators to
render their images
with incredible complexity and detail
but it's easy for the viewer to get lost
as a consequence whereas
a movie like sleeping beauty
you know exactly where to look because
everything that isn't relevant is
faded out to some degree and that which
is relevant is high resolution
and so the artist is helping the viewer
view the
image by making decisions about what is
highlighted and what isn't
and that's part of how the artist allows
the image to tell a story because
the artist can guide the attention of
the viewer
by making careful choices about what's
foreground and what's background
yeah and that reminds me of my thinking
that nowadays graphics are too sharp
they too chewed on properly all you have
to do is swallow
it's just there for you completely
everything is in focus
everything every single detail it's very
saturated
there's no mystery and it's not how my
eyes see maybe it's the poor vision
maybe no it's not how anybody's eye sees
it's not how i see and i need it to be
realistic
i mean the way we see is when we look at
something straight on
what we're directly looking at is in
high resolution but
as we move beyond the center of our
vision to the periphery everything
becomes much less high resolution
and that's because while we have limited
visual computational resources but
we we view what's most important in high
detail and late
everything else go
and that is obvious absolutely obvious
but if you look at every single one of
them
they're not in focus they're not
perfectly sharp
and that's on purpose and what do you
think that does
it gives them a dream like quality
that's one thing i noticed about
reminds us what we saw like 30 40 years
ago
and forgot how beautiful it was
rule nine if old memories still upset
you
write them down carefully and completely
this i believe was saint anthony
there's a number of famous
representations of saint anthony being
tormented by demons
we're all tormented by the demons of our
imagination
regrets fears paranoias
perhaps other people in our
representations
and he's peaceful in this image despite
this torment i thought this was an
extremely effective
image jordan look at the eyes
doesn't it remind you of anybody
who is it that's you
i've noticed many times in your lectures
in your interviews you're looking for
answers
look up and look up exactly like that
maybe not as tormented but you always
look up on the angle not straight
slightly on the angle like that now i'd
say that tormented
so i just wanted to be relatable
well i guess
you need to look up to find
what it is that makes the torment
worthwhile
and you're fortunate if you find that
rule 10
that was the one where we have
to make some construction
work on his feet plan and work
diligently to
maintain the romance in your
relationship yes and you're very
fortunate if you can do that
that's for sure another dance
and this was do you remember the image
i sent you do you remember the artist
was it
i can't remember unfortunately on
the kiss yeah i can check it out right
now
was it also gustav d'oray it was
inspired by aubry birdsley aubry
birdsley yeah beardsley
yes that was my only reference just one
picture
so
the fact when you see a couple moving
harmoniously together
and they seem to belong together the
reason they seem to belong together is
because
they're mimicking each other in their
posture
and that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily doing exactly the same thing
but the manner in which one person holds
their body is related to the manner in
which the other person is holding their
body and
you see this with mothers and children
so if you if you take videos of
mothers who are in a good mental state
with their infants
and you speed them up videoing the
mother and the infant you see that
they're engaged in a continual dance of
reaction and response but if you do that
with depressed mothers then
you don't get the same rhythm and
harmony in the interactions
and that's because the relationship is
disrupted by the depression
so in this representation these two are
very
harmoniously linked together and they've
they're maintaining the romance in their
relationship
and the chapter is a discussion of the
multitude
of of
problems that have to be solved in a
relationship for that
romance to be maintained across time
it's as if romance if you think about it
you might think about it as a form of
play
and play is very easily disrupted among
children if children are in any
powerful emotional state that will
interfere with their play
all their needs in some sense have to be
taken care of before they
before play will emerge and
there's some that also seems to be the
case
to some large degree with regard to the
relationship between men and women
or between two intimate partners
there's many things that have to be
solved properly for
the romance to be maintained across time
and rule 12
be grateful in spite of your suffering
another saint
images that have become much rarer
in the modern world
so tell me about this image
well again not overly expressive
at peace
he looks like he's part of the tree
yep again not everything in focus again
it's tree that doesn't exactly look like
a tree
and you can't see the bottom of the tree
which often happens
in real life you don't see every single
branch of the tree when you're looking
on the man
and so why did i did i hadn't noticed
that before
do you know why you decided to make the
bottom of the tree
obscured it wasn't a conscious decision
well
so then what it looks like is that his
legs now become the trunk of the tree
huh oh i see that
and they and they mirror the branches
the major branches in the tree
exactly so you're you're indicating
that's a really good example of how
the visual imagination can supersede the
conscious knowledge you of course you
don't
know why you made all the decisions you
made in these images how in the world
could you possibly know
and the image should contain way more
than you think i mean if you diligently
worked at it
and you know if you had planned a
drawing that said well i'm going to
give a man the strength of a tree it's
doubtful that you could have consciously
come up with a solution that would be
better than the one that you picked as a
consequence of your aesthetic judgment
yes so he's rooted powerfully i mean
what you have there is that what's
rooted powerfully in the earth is his
feet and his legs
and you've indicated that that's a more
powerful rooting
a more significant rooting than the
rooting of the tree itself
there's a bird in the background yeah
you've noticed and that made you laugh
i'm happy you noticed why
because that was intentional
birth is a freedom
all right so i'm going to close this up
but i have but i want to ask you
something else
which is i suppose the question i wanted
answered more than any other question
that i could put to you
what has been the consequence for you of
having undertaken this job
what's happened i mean partly as a
consequence of making the
images but you've had some attention
directed your way now
because of the book and there's going to
be a lot more coming because of this
video and because the book will be out
march 2nd
what what's changed for you
nothing yet nothing changed yet i don't
know what's gonna come
maybe you do no i don't i have
no idea if and what
but i've accomplished what i wanted and
what i wanted is
to make you smile during the period of
difficulty
and michaela tipped me off
every time you saw an art she would tell
me dad said
oh my god and that would make my day
well i appreciate that very much and i i
i'm very happy to have the illustrations
in my book
very surreal i think they're a very
they're a great addition to the book
and they're they're not yet next week i
you know i have pre-prints i have the
pdfs and so i i haven't seen how the
images look in the final
production yet um i like the images in
my first book
these are nicely different i
they're they're more romantic they're
more fairy tale like
they're more elusive in some sense
i hope people like them a lot i suspect
that they will
and i hope that the kind of attention
that you want comes your way kind of
attention that you
that would be best for you comes your
way as a consequence of doing this
thank you thank you very much for all
your work
absolutely welcome you helped us solve a
very difficult problem at a very
difficult time
that was my intention nothing else
well it's lovely to meet you i hope we
get to do it in person
we will and maybe we'll talk again
publicly some months after the book is
released
and we can discuss the consequences then
that would be nice is there anything
else that you'd like to say
just that i'm very happy to meet you
nothing else i'm just very happy to see
you
talking to me off the screen
well it was good to get to know you and
thank you very much
and we'll make this enter into an
interesting visual display
as well as an interesting conversation
all right
thank you very much
[Music]
you